[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا المشاهدين الكرام
في منظمه النقابيه وسياسيه اثريه الاحد في
الرباط احتجاجا على ارتفاع الاسعار في ظل
التضخم الذي يشهده المغرب هذا العام
عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من الرباط السيد عبد
العاطي ربيعه عضويه
الجبهه الوطنيه الاجتماعيه
شكرا شكرا لكم على الدعوه الكريم وشكرا
لضيوفتك يا رب مرحبا كل الترحيب بيك وشكرا
جزيلا لك من جديد على تلبيه هذه الدعوه
رحبنا وانت ايضا بضيفي في الجانب المقابل
للسيد عبد المنعم الكزان الصحفي والبحث في
علم الاجتماع
اهلا بكم ومرحبا وشكرا جزيلا لك على تلبيه
الدعوه سيد عبد المنعم الجزدان
شكرا جزيلا رونالدو
الانطلاق في هذه الحلقه قبل طرح السؤال
عليكم بشكل استثنائي
وعن همم تاهل المنتخب المغربي الى الدوري
الربع النهائي لاول مره في تاريخ السؤال
الاول انا سيد عبد العاطي ربيعه عضو امانه
الجبهه الوطنيه الاجتماعيه مرحبا من جديد
باختصار شديد المغرب همم في ربع النهائي
هذا في الحقيقه حدث عظيم بالنسبه للشعب
المغربي اول مره يتاهل المنتخب المغربي
الى ربع النهايه وهذه سابقه في التاريخ
كنا دائما نتحدث عن جيل 86 الان هناك جيل
جديد
ابناء الشعب المغربي بقياده مدرب مغربي
يدل على ان الاطار المغربي يجب ان تعطى
كامل الفرص في ان يحققه حول جميعا اذا
نهنئ الشعب المغربي
افريقيا
لكل ايضا بهذا الانجاز الذي يعتبر انجازا
تاريخيا ونتمنى ان يستمر على هذا المنوال
المنتخب هنا ان يصل الى ابعد الحدود وشكرا
لكم همم فرحه عالي مانجاز تاريخي والمغرب
يتيح باسبانيا بركلات الترجيح يصل دور
الثمانيه في كاس العالم لاول مره سيد عبد
المنعم الجزال
لا زلت نصرت المنتخب الوطني مستمره
بهذه المناسبه
الافارقه والامازيغيه والعرب على الانجاز
باعتباره الانجاز للجميع ونتمنى نتمنى
المواصلات
كذلك نحن مع الاطار الوطني دائما وهنا
عندما يكون الاطار الوطني
في محطه اخرى طيب نعود شكرا جزيلا لكما
نعود الى الموضوع على الحلقه الرئيسيه
وهذه التظاهره التي دعت اليها اذا تنسيقيه
الجبهه الاجتماعيه المغربيه
مصدر من المديريه العامه للامن الوطني اكد
ان عدد المشاركين تراوح ما بين 1200 و15
الرئيسي الى اي مدى هذا العدد يمثل الموقف
العام
مغربي همم سيد عبد العاطي ربيع عضو امانه
الجبهه الوطنيه الاجتماعيه التي دعت الى
هذه التظاهر
اولا في الحقيقه انا اعتقد ان الرقم
يتجاوز هذا بكثير الرقم المعلن عليه همم
من طرف الاجل الجهات الرسميه نحن نعتقد ان
الرقم تجاوز ربما 7,000 او 8000 همم من
طرف همم الجماهير الشعبيه التي حجت الى
الرباط كانت مسيره طويله جدا همم
بمختلف همم مكونات الجبهه الاجتماعيه
المغربيه
الكل الحاجه الى الرباط ليعبر عن غضبه من
النتيجه
في الشعار المركز الذي همم كان هو شعار
شعارنا في هذه التظاهره وهو جميعا ضد
الغلاء والقمع اذا بالنسبه للرقم الرقم
كان كبير جدا وهو رقم معبر جدا لان همم
لانه لا بد ان نستحضر السياق العام الذي
جاءت فيه
هذه المسير وهذه المحطه النظاميه اولا
سواء ذاتيا او موضوع على مستوى المواضيع
ونحن نعيش يعني او الشعب المغربي ككل يعيش
معنا هذه الفرحه نتيجه ما يحققها منتخبنا
الوطني ومنتخبنا المغربي
وبالتالي يعني للخروج في هذا في ظل هذا
الشروط الموضوعيه كان كان يدعوا لدينا
مجموعه متخوت ولكن كان لابد من ان نعبر عن
غضبنا الى جانب فرحتنا بانجازات المنتخب
اليوم خصوصا على مستوى القدره الشرعيه
وعلى المستوى غلاء الاسعار
حضور مميزه جدا وسياتي محطات اخرى اكل
والرقم كان معبرا جدا يقول ضيفي سيد عبد
العاطي ربيع بالنسبه لك سي عبد المنعم
الجزال الى اي مدى بالنظري الى حجم هاي
الى اي مدى من وجهه نظرك انت تعبر هذه
المظاهره والتظاهر فعلا عن توجه الراي
العام المغربي
همم
1200 الى 1500 اذا في حدود 2,000 شخص على
ابعد التقدير
المهم ان هذه العدد الكيس بالدرجه الاولى
يعني توافق مجموعه من المواطنين المغاربه
الشيء الذي اكدته
المندوبيه السالميه تخطيط واكد والبركه
مجموعه
اخرى
المجموعه الشمس
اا لا احد ناشئ بها خصوصا بانه مجموعه من
المواطنين اصبحوا ينظرون الى بعض الهيئات
الحقوقيه
والنقابه باعتبارها فقط كائنات احتجاجيه
كما انها ترابي انه همم هناك ركوب على
مجموعه من الاحداث في حين ان الغرض
الاساسي هو الخروج الى الاحتجاج من اجلها
من اجل غلاء المعيشه النقطه الثانيه كذلك
كذلك انه هناك نوع من تفريغ نفسي بالنسبه
انتصار المنتخب الوطني ايضا كذلك ان
السياق الدولي والمستوى
لا يمكن ان يسهم ان همم
الاحتجاج لن يتزاوج في جميع الاحوال همم
كذلك يجب ان في الانتباه انه هذه الهيئات
لن تستطيع يعني همم عدد كبير المواطنين
مقارتين معها الشاشه التي اوياه مثل مثلا
الاساتذه العرض التقاعد التعاقد او
المحامون او في حاجه معينه اطباء معينه
الممرضين اي بعباره اخرى ان التوجه العام
بالنسبه
للاحتجاج هناك اتجاه الاحوال الاحتجاجات
وفي اويه وليس باعتماد
النقابات او تنسيقيه معينه
سيعاقب ضيفي على هذه المؤشرات التي تضعف
العمل الاحتجاجي ولكن هذا التظاهر من حيث
المضمون هل كان فعلا همم مبررا سيد عبد
العاطي ربيع عضو امام الجبهه الوطنيه
الاجتماعيه
نعم نعم هو كان مبرر جدا
وانطلاقا مجموعه من المؤشرات او نتحدث
سابقا على مساله الغلاء الاسعار اذا
الاسعار
المستوى الدولي وتضاعفت السكن بعد المواد
التي تضعفت اثمنتها خمس او ست مرات في ظرف
اشهر ما نعيشه على مستوى المحروقات بالرغم
ان سعر البرميل على المستوى العالمي اليوم
يصل الى ادنى مستوياته فان سعر اللتر من
البنزين لازاله يتجاوز 14 درهم 15 درهم
هذا الشيء مؤثر في الحقيقه وينيم عن طبيعه
السياسيه الرسميه اذا هات هات هات تضارب
ما بين الاثمنه على مستوى الدوله الوطنيه
حول مساله همم قانون الماليه ميزان قانون
الميزانيه لسنه 23 وما جاء به من من من من
من الحقيقه امتيازات لصالح الباترون صحيح
همم الرا المشتركات الكبرى من تخفيضات
الضريبيه وغيرها في حين انه اثقل كاهل
فئات اخرى ولا راسهم يعني اصحاب نتحدث
الخدمات الحره من محامي وغيرهم
وقطاعات اخرى ايضا بالضريبه نفس الشيء ما
يعيشه همم
المغاربه بشكل يومي يعني نتحدث يوم عن
الارقام التي تتحدث على ان اكثر من ثلاث
ملايين ومئتين الف مغربيه
كلها مؤشرات وكلها مؤشرت الى جانب مؤشرات
اخرى كانت لابد ان دقه من خلالها ناقص
الخطر من خلال هذه المسيره احتجاجيه قبل
ان انهي لابد ان نتفاعل مع ضيفك الكريم
فيما يخص يعني المساله ان همم هذه همم
الاطارات وهي الاطارات التي تتحدثها عن
ضيفك بانها لا تعرفها غير الاحتجاج بالعكس
هذه الاطارات كما قلت سابقا فيها اطارات
نقابه
هي اليوم في حوار اجتماعي مع مع الحكومه
مركزيا وعلى مستوى مختلف قطاعته راسها
التعليم
وهناك اليوم ايضا فلوكاج على مستوى هذا
هذا هذه الحوارات الاجتماعيه نتحدث مثلا
على مستوى همم الحوار المركزي كان هناك
يعني اتفاق مسبق بتاريخ 30 ابريل يعني
بيوم واحد قبل فاتح ماي السابق على مساله
انه سيكون هناك تخفيض ضريب وسيكون هناك
زياده في الاجور اليوم الحكومه تتنصل من
كل هذه الوعود على مستوى همم القطاع
المستوى مثلا انقطاع التعليم كما قلت
سابقا هناك اليوم يعني همم الحوار متوقف
والنظام الاساسي لم يخرج بعد ومن بين
النقط العالقه ما تتحدث عنه ضيفه انا
المساله الاساتذه الذين فرض عليهم التعاقد
وادماجهم في الوظيفه العموميه وبالتالي
كلها يعني اشياء التي كانت لها الحاحيه في
ان نخرج الاحتجاج في هذا التاريخ بالرغم
من كما قلت سابقا شروط الذاتيه والموضوعيه
وخصوص شروط الموضوعيه المتعلقه بهذا
الفرحه التي نعيشها جميعا همم بفوز
المنتخب الوطني همم الصور الصور تؤكد بان
الرقم هو اكبر مما هو الرسمي واضح حجيات
الرسميه لن تقول الرقم الحقيقي لانه دائما
ستحاول ان تبخص العدد الحقيقي الذي خرج
الاحتجاج وتحيات السيد عبد المنعم الجزدان
همم السؤال الذي يطرح الفعل نشه التصاعدا
الغضب الاجتماعي في المغرب هل نحن فعلا
امام حكومه تجسس زواج المال والسلطه وتدعم
الراس مال الاحتكار كما يقول المنسق
الوطني لجبهه الوطنيه الاجتماعيه
في ظل الارتفاع الاسعار وتدهور المقدوره
همم الشرائيه همم كيف ترد على ضيفه تفضل
اولانا في تقديري اولا يجب ان يسجل بانه
الحكومه هي حكومه منتخبه اذا كان الشعب
قبيله بالزواج المال السلطه
اعتقد انه اغلب الفئات الهيئات هي هي
الانتخابات ولم تحضر بالاجماء الشعبي على
مستوى الانتقالات كانت يعني اكثر
نزاهه في علاقتها مع مجموعه من المراقبين
الدوليين ومراقبين الاحزاب السياسيه
الحكومه او في شرعيه البرلمان بهذا الشكل
ولكن يمكن ان نسجل مجموعه من الامور ان
هناك
تاخر على مستوى مجموعه من المشاريع التي
تحرك فيها الحكومه لكن يج نسجل ايضا ان
المغاربه واعون بالسياق الاقليمي والسياق
الدولي خصوصا ما بعد كورونا او ازمه الحرب
الاوكرانيه الشعب المغربي
مساله اساسي هاي يعني كانت سبب في مجموعه
من
التراث التي ادت الى التضخم والتي ادت
كذلك الى همم
بنسبه الارقام هي الارقام يعني من طرف
المندوبيه
بشيء جديد هذا تقرير المندوبيه
البنك المركزي باعتبارها همم عفوا ال- ال-
المصطلح همم المغرب باعتبارها
تقوم باحصائيات بشكل مباشر التي
بتقديم مجموعه من الاستشارات وتقديم
مجموعه طيب همم نقطه ثانيه همم
المساله المساله لا تعتقد لا لا ترتبط
بالكم
المساله ترتبط بانه انه فعلا هو لان لو
التقارير الرسميه تؤكد بانه
هناك همم هناك عجوه هناك قال المعيشه
بالتالي انه همم مطالب انشروعه همم الغير
مشروع انه الركوب على هذه المطالب وقد
لاحظنا في مجموعه من المحطات على مساله
الركوب على همم هذه همم الازمه همم ولكن
حتى اعود اليه يكسب العاطي سيد عبد العاطي
ربيعا ضيف يقرر انه تم تتاخر ولكن ثم تهدد
ايضا تقول اطراف اخرى مدافع عن هذه
الحكومه والازمه الصحيه تضررت منها كل
الدول وفي مواجهه الاحتجاجات ضد الغلاء
الحكومه تؤكد انها تنتهي السياسه اجتماعيه
ما الخصوصا تنفيذ برنامج لتعميم التغطيه
الصحيه على كافه المغارب احد 10 مليون
مغربي من ذوي الدخل المحدود ادرج ضمن
المستفيدين من التغطيه الصحيه من دون اداء
رسوم اشتراك في يوم وصف بالتاريخي في
المغرب بالاضافه الى المراهنه المستمره
على تحريك الاستثمارات العامه والخاصه
لتنشيط الاقتصاد بالاعلان عن اطلاق صندوق
استثمار سيادي بقيمه فوق 4 مليارات
والقائمه طويله بمعنى يقول لك كثيرون
اليوم ان هذه الحكومه لا تدخر جهدا في
ظرفيه همم دوليه همم صعبه همم لا تؤثر فقط
على المغرب بل على العالم تفضل سيد عبد
العزيز
انطلق من مساله الركوب مساله الركوب هي
فعلا هناك من يحاول ان يرثق بهيئات معينه
وهيئات وطنيه شعبيه وهيئات قانونيه لها
زعما- قوانين ومؤسسه وفق القانون المغربي
بقوانين الاساسيه وحاصله على وصول ايداعها
الى ذلك وبالتالي فهي تمثل جزء من
المغاربه هل اليوم مساله الركوب هل نقص
هذه
الديمقراطيه هل نقصي هاتي لهيئه النقديه
هل نقصي هاتي الجمعه ليكون يعني جزء او
بعض الذين يسيرون سياسات الرسميه كما هي
على يعني بالنسبه يكونوا راضيين على على
هذه
العكسيه تناظر وفقا مبادئها وفقا مبادئها
التي تتاسس اساسا عن الدفاع عن الضمائر
الشعبيه
من اكثر
عفوا سيد عبد العاطي ربيع كما قلت
ما قلت بالنسبه للجبهه الاجتماعيه تتكون
من اكثر من 41 هيئه قانونيه وهي هيهات
ديمقتك كما قلت سابقا نقا بيا وسياسيه
وجمعويه وهي تعبر عن
عريضه من الشعب المغربي بالنسبه للمساله
الانتخابات نحن جميعا لاحظنا كيف المرض
الانتخابات من خلال شراء الدماء من خلال
الرشوه من خلال استعمال ديال المال الحرام
من خلال مجموعه من الاشياء من خلال الحمله
السابقه لاوانيها من طرف مكون سياسي معينه
التي استمرت تقريبا لمده خمس سنوات وقبل
يعني منذ تنصيب الحكومه التي كانت قبل اذن
لا يمكننا الحديث عن الحكومه بشكل
الديمقراطي باستحضار مساله نسبه المقاطعه
كلها هذه همم
الاشياء تؤكد يعني طبيعه
الحكومهونها هل تقررون بها هل تعترفون بها
هل تسمنونها حتى تجيب تجيب على سؤالي
اليوم
تجاوزنا 100 يوم من عمر هذه متجاوزنا سنه
من من عمرها هذه الحكومه ماذا تتحقق هذا
السؤال وما تتحقق لان لكي نقوم بتقييم
الحقيقيه يجب ان ننطلقه من مؤشرات اللي هي
حقيقيه واقعيه مؤشرات عدديه ممكن ان نقيس
عليها لم يتحقق اي شيء اين هي الوعود التي
وعدت بها مكونات هذه الحكومه من زيادات
ومن غيرها وكانت ان ونعلم ان الانتخابات
وقد قدمت وعود لم يخفى بها اي شيء حينما
نتحدث مساله عن مساله تسجيل الاجتماعي
والسجل الصحيح هو كانت هناك تجارب سابقا
امانه همم على سبيل المثال مساله راميد
حينما نتحدث عن صنادق استثمار هل هناك
تقييم لمسلسل المغرب اخضر واحنا اليوم
نعيش يعني من جهه سنوات من الجفاف
المتعاقب اخرى هو استنزاف للفرشه المائيه
من خلال التوجيه همم نعم همم
كما قلت بسرعه همم خلال استنزاف الفرشه
المائيه من خلال توجيه يعني الفلاحه او
الفلاح الكبار الى زراعه بعنوان مثل
الافوكادو مثل البطيخه همم الشرطه الشرطه
علم الاجتماع
اولا من العيب انه هيئه شاركت في
الانتخابات كان الاولى بها ان تقدم الطعون
بالنسبه تقدم الطعون
السلطه القضائيه
القول انه هناك قد يكون قد يكون ولكن لم
تؤثر على عمليه الوقت
لدي 30 ثانيه فقط
30 من اجل الختم اعتقد بانه الاحتجاجت عند
الشعب المغربي واعي بانه هناك ازمه وبين
انه الحكومه صحيح ان هناك
هذا المستوى المستوى الاداء الحكومي نتمنى
ان تسريع الحكومه في تنفيذ الجماعه من
الوعود على حسب
اجتماعي كذلك على راسها اشكال البطاله
كذلك مجموعه من الاشكالات
ونطالب اذا كان هناك هناك
او كان هناك فساد ان تقوم بواجبهاش
باعتبارها واجب اعتبارها همم
30 20 سنه
الوطنيه الاجتماعيه
ازاي انا صحفي والباحث في علم الاجتماع
شكرا جزيلا لكم على تربيه هذه الدعوه كنتم
معنا في فقرها لوجه